Ja natürlich. Ich habe leider Ihren Namen nicht ganz verstanden. Wie heißen Sie bitte?
Ich bin Toprak. Toprak? Was ist das für ein Name? Toprak meint eine Erde. Ich bin Türken. Das meint eine Erde.
Ach, Sie kommen aus der Türkei. Sie sprechen aber gut Deutsch. Das ist sehr schön. Danke. Sie sind sehr nett.
Das beruht auf Gegenseitigkeit. Ich glaube, das kommt, weil Sie so nett sind. Bitte schön. Danke schön.
Ich bin ein Verständiger. Sie sind einverstanden?
Aber natürlich gerne. Wenn ein so ein netter freundlicher Arzt ist, dann bin ich einverstanden.
Bevor Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden kommen, muss ich noch ein paar Fragen zu Ihren persönlichen Daten stellen.
Falls etwas unklar ist, bitte unterbrechen Sie mich. Und wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Manuela Kuta.
Kuta?
Kuta. Wie in Buta, aber mit K.
Können Sie Ihre Namen kurz wissen?
Kuta. K wie K. U. K. U. T oder wie Toprak. Und nochmal T. Emil Richard. Kuta.
Manuela M. A. N. U. E. L. L. E.
Mit einem L. Manuela.
Einmal L. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 35.
Darf ich Frau Kuta sagen?
Frau Kuta, natürlich, ja.
Entschuldigung, können Sie wiederholen? Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 35 Jahre alt.
Ich bin 35 Jahre alt. Wann sind Sie genau geboren, Frau Kuta?
Wann bin ich genau geboren? Ich bin geboren am 23.3.1996. Nein, 1990.
1991.
Könnten Sie die Monat wiederholen? Welchen Monat war das?
März, 23. März.
Wie groß sind Sie, Frau Kuta?
Ich bin 1,73 Meter.
Wie viel wiegen Sie aktuell?
Ein bisschen zu viel, 85 Kilo.
Haben Sie ungewohnt ab 30 genommen, Frau Kuta? Nein, nein.
Sie haben ... Okay, was kann ich für Sie tun, Frau Kuta?
Was für Sie tun Sie?
Genau. Also der Grund, warum ich heute da bin, das trifft sich gut.
Ich bin schwindlig.
Entschuldigung, ich konnte nicht verstanden. Es gab eine Verwindung, ein Problem.
Ich habe seit zwei Wochen zunehmende Kopfschmerzen.
Zeitweise ist es mir sehr schwindlig. Und ich fühle mich einfach nicht wohl.
Sind die Beschwerden plötzlich aufgetreten?
Nein, kann man nicht sagen. Also es ist langsam aufgetreten.
Aber es ist schlimmer geworden. Es wird nicht besser als ich.
Ich nehme ab und zu ein Paracetamol, dann wird es gut.
Aber ich möchte ständig jeden Tag Schmerztabletten nehmen. Deswegen bin ich heute hier.
Tritt die Kopfschmerzen morgens oder abends?
Eigentlich immer, den ganzen Tag. Immer wieder mal mehr oder mal weniger.
Wie ist die Kopfschmerzen? Eine pochende, polosative oder berühmte?
Nein, das pocht nicht. Das ist einfach anhaltend. Das ist immer da.
Und manchmal ist es mehr, wie gesagt. Manchmal weniger.
Drückend oder pochend?
Ja, das ist der ganze Kopf. Das ist mehr so im Hinterkopf.
Und nach vorne. Und es ist eher so ein bisschen drückend, würde ich sagen.
Aber Lichtempfindlichkeit?
Lichtempfindlichkeit nicht, aber ich habe manchmal auch so ein bisschen Druck auf den Augen.
Das ist etwas unangenehm. Oder wenn ich mich nach vorne beuge mit dem Kopf, dann wird es schlimmer.
Oder wenn ich meinen Kopf etwas hin und her drehe, dann wird es auch schlimmer.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie schwindelig sind. Seit wann sind Sie schwindelig?
Ja, auch seit zwei Wochen. Seitdem diese Kopfschmerzen angefangen haben.
Wie ist der Schwindelig?
Sie meinen, wie ist der Schwindel? Wie ist der Schwindel? Nicht wie ist der schwindelig.
Wie ist der Schwindel? Ich habe das Gefühl, es schwankt ein bisschen.
Ja, und manchmal, wenn ich mich hinlege, da habe ich das Gefühl, es dreht sich.
Aber haben Sie etwas eingenommen als Medikament?
Ja, gut. Wie gesagt, Paracetamol nehme ich manchmal ein.
Paracetamol gut helfen?
Ja, das hilft für ein paar Stunden, aber dann kommt es wieder.
Haben Sie Taubheitsgefühle oder Belegungen? Nein, das nicht.
Nein, ich habe manchmal so eine leichte Übelkeit. Das kann ich noch sagen.
Ich fühle mich einfach nicht wohl. Der ganze Körper ist etwas komisch.
Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, die Haut ist manchmal etwas komisch.
Haut? Was meinen Sie mit dem Haut?
Ja, das fühlt sich am ganzen Körper ein bisschen komisch an, würde ich sagen.
Kann ich nicht so gut beschreiben.
Sind Sie die Hautfarbänderung bemerkt?
Nein, die Hautfarbänderung habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Sehstörungen oder Hörstörungen?
Also Sehstörungen habe ich nicht, aber wie gesagt, ich habe manchmal ein bisschen Druck auf den Augen.
Das ist etwas unangenehm, aber so eine richtige Sehstörung habe ich bisher noch nicht.
Strahlen Sie sich irgendwo hinaus?
Meistens ist es ein bisschen der Hinterkopf und geht an die Schläfe, an die Seiten.
Aber Ausstrahlen habe ich jetzt nicht.
Nehmen Sie Bluthochdruckmedikamente rein?
Nein, ich hatte mal, von daher bin ich froh, dass Sie da sind, vor drei Jahren eine Schwangerschaft.
Und im Rahmen der Schwangerschaft hatte ich mal hohen Blutdruck gehabt.
Und da waren auch die Symptome sehr ähnlich, so wie jetzt.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein.
Haben Sie Atemnot, Herzrasen, Herzstopper?
Nein, das habe ich alles nicht, nein.
Haben Sie eine Verdauerung, Probleme, Verstoppung, Durchfall?
Ach so, nein, nein, das habe ich nicht, nein.
Ich habe die Tage ein bisschen weniger Appetit, aber das was Sie beschreiben oder fragen habe ich nicht.
Sind bei Ihnen Vorerkrankungen und OP bekannt?
Nein, wie gesagt, hat diese Blutdruckproblematik im Rahmen meiner letzten Schwangerschaft.
Sonst habe ich keine Vorerkrankungen, nein.
Aber nach der Schwangerschaft haben Sie gemessen diese Blutdruck?
Ja, damals, nach der Schwangerschaft, war der Blutdruck wieder in Ordnung.
Danach habe ich nicht nochmal gemessen, nein.
Sind die Blutdruckhochdruck nach dem 20. Woche aufgetreten?
Ach Gott, ich kann mich jetzt nicht mehr erinnern, aber das war gegen Ende der Schwangerschaft, ja.
Ende, ja. Sie hatten damals viele Beine öde, oder nicht?
Ein bisschen, war nicht so viel. Ich hatte aber viel Gewicht zugenommen, fast über 20 Kilo.
Aktuell ist Ihnen eine geschwollenes Bein aufgefallen?
Nein, im Moment habe ich keine geschwollenen Beine.
Moment, okay. Sie hatten auch keine Zuckerkrankheit, ja?
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht gehabt, nein.
Würden Sie schon einmal operiert, auch nicht?
Nein, nein, ich hatte bisher keine Operation.
Waren Sie in den letzten Monaten beim Krankenhaus oder Arztlichen?
Nein, nein, ich komme jetzt das erste Mal zu Ihnen.
Erstes Mal, okay. Nehmen Sie Medikamente regelmäßig ein aus Herddiskarztformalen?
Nein, nein, ich habe jetzt keine regelmäßigen Medikamente.
Wie gesagt, Paracetamol lebe ich auch nicht regelmäßig ein.
Das war jetzt nur die letzten Tage ein paar Mal.
Wie ist die Stimmung in den letzten Monaten?
Es war alles ganz gut. Ich arbeite, habe einen Bürojob, bin sehr zufrieden.
Also es gab keine Probleme, nein.
Kommen Sie mit dem Stress gut zurecht?
Ja, ja, also es ist alles ganz okay. Bei der Arbeit habe ich keine Probleme.
Bei der Arbeit keine Probleme, okay.
Rauchen Sie?
Nein.
Nehmen Sie Alkohol so sich?
Nein, Alkohol trinke ich auch nicht.
Sehr schön, sehr schön. Nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich, das ist eine Routinefrage.
Prozumieren Sie Drogen?
Drogen, ach so, nein, nein.
Sind bei Ihnen Allergie und Unverträglichkeit bekannt?
Also Allergie jetzt nicht direkt, aber Unverträglichkeit.
Ich vertrage keine Laktose, also Milchprodukte, dann bekomme ich leicht Blähungen und Bauchschmerzen.
Und einige Gewürze vertrage ich nicht, das sind Curry und Roter Pfeffer.
Hab ich vergessen, Entschuldigung, ich möchte ein bisschen zurückgehen.
Wie stark ist Ihr Kopfschmerz auf einer Schmerzensuppe? Von 1 bis 10, wobei 10 ist unerträglich.
Ja gut, so unerträglich mit Stufe 10 war es jetzt nicht, aber ich würde sagen so 3 bis 4.
3 bis 4. Wenn Sie schlafen, verhindert Ihre Kopfschmerzen oder nicht?
Wenn ich schlafe, merke ich das nicht, natürlich nicht.
Brauchen Sie im dunkel Raum?
Nein, ich brauche keinen dunklen Raum, aber das macht keinen Unterschied.
Und Geräusche stört auch die?
Nein, da merke ich keinen Unterschied, nein.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie wichtige Vorerkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Mein Vater hat einen hohen Blutdruck, das weiß ich, der nimmt auch Medikamente, aber ich weiß nicht, was er da einnimmt.
Meine Mutter ist relativ gesund, die hat eigentlich keine Probleme, die hatte aber vor 2 Jahren mal eine Gallenblasen-OP.
Sonst wüsste ich jetzt nichts.
Wann war das, Gallenblasen-OP?
Vor 2 Jahren bei meiner Mutter.
Wann war der letzte Regen?
Da habe ich jetzt eigentlich keine Probleme, das ist vor 2 Wochen ungefähr.
Verhütten Sie?
Nein.
Keine Medikamente oder keine Filme?
Nein, nein, nein. Mein Mann hat sich sterilisieren lassen, von daher.
Kinderplanung, Kinderrutsch ist abgeschlossen.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Ich habe 3 Kinder, wie gesagt, die Jüngste ist jetzt 2 Jahre alt.
Und dann die Mittler ist 5 und die Älteste ist 8.
Stimmen Sie gerade oder nicht?
Nein, nein, nicht mehr.
Ok. Sie wohnen mit Ihrem Mann und Familie?
Ja, mit der Familie, genau.
Ok. Was machen Sie von beruflich?
Ich arbeite im Büro, ich mache die Büroleitung.
Büroleitung?
Ja, von einer großen Firma.
Waren Sie in den letzten 6 Monaten im Ausland oder im Wald?
Im Wald, nein. Wir gehen immer wieder mal, aber jetzt waren wir in den letzten 6 Monaten nicht.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, ja. Im Rahmen der Schwangerschaft hat meine Gynäkologie alles kontrolliert.
Das war alles komplett.
Ist Ihnen ein Hautausschlag aufgefallen in Ihrem Körper?
Nein, ist mir nichts aufgefallen. Sind Sie fertig, Herr Doktor?
Die letzte Frage. Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ja, ich versuche ein bisschen Fitness zu machen und ein bisschen Sport, aber eigentlich nicht so regelmäßig.
Ich fahre manchmal Fahrrad, aber sonst in letzter Zeit wenig.
Ok. Ich werde nochmal gucken.
Meinerseits habe ich alle wichtige Fragen gestellt. Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, ich würde mich freuen, wenn Sie herausfinden, was es ist.
So langsam wird das sehr belastend und unangenehm.
Ja, eigentlich kann ich nicht genau sagen. Ich muss ihre Vitalparameter überprüfen und ich muss auch körperlich untersuchen.
Und natürlich Blutdruck und Blutzucker muss ich kontrollieren.
Das heißt, nehmen Sie heute Abend noch Blut ab?
Heute, ja.
Das ist sehr gut. Wunderbar.
Ja, heute. Je nach Ergebnis werde ich mit meinem Chef sprechen.
Ok.
Sobald alle Ergebnisse vorliegen, würde ich gerne mit Ihnen informieren.
Ich würde Sie informieren. Ok, alles klar.
Gut, dann danke ich Ihnen recht herzlich. Dann nehme ich kurz Platz und dann sagen Sie Bescheid, wenn Sie soweit sind.
Ok, danke.
Gut. Es sind noch Fragen von Kollegen und Kolleginnen. Keine Frage. Hat Dr. Toprak alles richtig gemacht?
Alles richtig gemacht, aber ich habe keine Verdachtdiagnose.
Also, ich gebe jetzt ein paar Ergebnisse. Laborwerte. Blutbild, Leukos sind in Ordnung. Hemoglobin ist 10,8.
Eisen ist etwas niedrig. Niere ist in Ordnung. Leber ist in Ordnung. TSH ist 0,01.
0,01, ok.
Sie hat einen Blutdruck von 180 zu 100. Blutdruck 180 zu 100. Puls ist 72. EKG ist unauffällig. Sinusrhythmus.
EKG ist normal. Aber Sie haben gesagt, dass TSH-Werte 0,01. Ja, das ist sehr niedrig, negativ.
Hypoteroid.
Und, genau.
Urin ist auch in Ordnung.
Die Period ist regelmäßig.
Ok. Letzte Frage. Ist Ihnen Haarausfall?
Ein bisschen, ja. In letzter Zeit habe ich verstärkter Haarausfall. Ja, das stimmt.
Ist Ihnen ein geschwollenes Hals etwas?
Nein, am Hals habe ich nichts gemerkt. Nein.
Für größerte Knoten?
Nein, nein. Habe ich nichts gemerkt. Nein.
Haben Sie jetzt Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose, Herr Kollege?
Nein, hitzeempfindlich bin ich nicht. Ok. Sind Sie soweit? Oder sind nur Fragen von Kollegen?
Ja.
Ähnliche Beschwerden habe ich schon gehabt. Das habe ich vorhin auch in der Anamnese gesagt.
Das waren ähnliche Beschwerden im Rahmen von Blutdruck bei der Schwangerschaft.
Bei der Schwangerschaft. Aber während des Schwangerschafts hatten Sie auch die Schilddrüse über Funktionen oder?
Nein, da hatte ich keine Schilddrüsenproblematik.
Ok. Sollen wir weitermachen?
Ja, genau.
Oder brauchen Sie noch ein paar Minuten?
Wahrscheinlich ja. Eine Minute. Eine Minute, alles klar. Eine Minute.
Das war ein bisschen kompliziert.
Ja, das ist ein internistisches Problem.
Sie haben die Diagnose durcheinander, oder?
Nein, das ist ein...
Eine Gepertreuse, ok. Aber Sie haben, ok.
Herr Doktor, Sie sind ein Gynäkologe. Das müssen Sie wissen.
Ja, ok. Präglanz. Sie haben Präglanz.
Ich bin aber nicht schwanger.
Ja, aber Sie haben. Sie sind nicht schwanger.
Ja, Kopfschmerzen und Bluthochdruck.
Wir können das nachher nochmal genau besprechen.
Ok.
Das heißt Spannungskopfschmerzen. Nicht spannende Kopfschmerzen, sondern Spannungskopfschmerzen.
Ok, Herr Doktor. Eine Minute ist bald rum.
Eine Minute ist vorbei.
Ich mache ein bisschen Stress.
Ok. So wie in der Klinik.
Hallo, guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Hallo, guten Tag. Toprak.
Darf ich eine Patientin vorstellen?
Aber natürlich. Klar, bitte schön. Was haben Sie denn?
Frau Manuel Lecuter ist 5,5 Jahre alt, geboren am 23. März 1991.
Sie ist 1 Meter 73 groß.
Sie ist 1 Meter.
Sie ist 1 Meter 73 groß. Sie wiegt aktuell 85 Kilogramm.
Aktuell 85 Kilogramm. Nicht aktuell, aktuell.
Sie wiegt aktuell 85 Kilogramm.
Sie stellte sich heute bei uns seit zwei Wochen zunehmend, langsam aufgetrennt in der Sefalge vor.
Sie stellte sich mit seit zwei Wochen zunehmend, langsam aufgetreten in der Sefalge vor.
Sie stellte sich mit seit zwei Wochen zunehmend, langsam aufgetreten und anhalten.
Tachikardi, Tachibne, deren Verstopfung wurden verneint. Sie klagte über Appetitlosigkeit
und sie hat Parasite-Mol eingenommen. Das hilft weniger.
Das hilft nur kurzfristig oder das helfe nur kurzfristig und konjunktiv?
Ja, genau. Und was noch, letzte Regel war vor zwei Wochen, sie hatte ähnliche Beschwerden
in der Schwangerschaft. Wann war die letzte Schwangerschaft?
Vor zwei Jahren. Die Kinder waren zwei Jahre alt. Sie hatten ähnliche Beschwerden während der Schwangerschaft.
Als Op und Vorerkrankungen unauffällig, keine Vorerkrankungen.
Stopp, stopp, stopp. Du musst den Satz schon richtig machen. Nicht Op unauffällig, sondern wie heißt der Satz?
Als Vorerkrankungen und Op gab es keine Vorerkrankungen und keine Voroperationen.
Sie hat keine Vorerkrankungen oder keine wesentlichen Vorerkrankungen und keine Voroperationen.
Genau. Nuxen an dem Meen ist unauffällig. Darf ich so sagen? Nuxen. Sie raucht nicht.
Sie konsumiert nicht Drogen, wurden verneint. Sie konsumiert keine Drogen.
Als Unverträglichkeit, Laktosintervall ist bekannt. Sie reagiert mit blechendem Bauch und auch mit einigen Gewürzen wie Curry und Vata.
Roter Pfeffer.
In Familienerkrankungen hat der Vater arteriale Hypertonie.
Mutter seitlich hat keine Vorerkrankungen und nur Cholesistektomie ist bekannt.
Sie hat drei Kinder, drei gesunde Kinder. Sie arbeitet im Büro. Sie hat keinen Stress beim Arbeiten.
Sie klagt auch die Alopezie.
Ich würde sagen, eher über leichten Haarausfall. Alopezie ist, wenn du richtig viel und Löcher hast.
Das ist ja nicht der Fall. Sie hat nur ein bisschen Haarausfall.
Genau.
Da muss man nochmal die Definition anschauen. Ich würde sagen, sie hat leichten Haarausfall.
Aufgrund der anämnistischen Angabe und geschilderten Beschwerden habe ich den Verdacht auf Hyperturose begleitend mit vorübergehenden arteriale Hypertonie.
Wie bezeichnet man die arteriale Hypertonie, wenn sie so hoch ist? Wie bezeichnet man die Notdruck oder die arteriale Hypertonie, wenn sie sehr hoch ist?
Das sind die Symptome. Hypertensive Krise.
Genau. Dann würde ich sagen, sie hat ein Labor chemisch eine Hyperturose, eine manifeste Hyperturose mit Blutdruckentgleisung oder mit einer hypertensiven Krise.
Und was hat sie noch? Was war das Labor, das Blutbild Hemoglobin?
Das war eine leichte Anämie.
Was war eine Anämie?
Das war Hemoglobinwerte 10,8.
Okay. Was war eine Art von Anämie?
Lokostos war normal.
Und Eisen? Wie war das Eisen?
Eisen habe ich nicht.
Hat sie gesagt. Eisen ist niedrig.
Eisen ist niedrig?
Ja, das habe ich vorhin gesagt.
Also hat sie was für eine Anämie?
Eine Mikrosterne Anämie. Das ist Eisenmangelanämie.
Genau. Sie hat eine Eisenmangelanämie.
Und eine weitere Abklärung. Und so ist es eine differenzielle Diagnose.
Die Anämie hat natürlich einen Labor.
Sie hat es schon gemacht.
Was ist ihre Differenzialdiagnose?
Differenzialdiagnose kann sein, Migraine kann sein, Spannung, Kopfschmerzen kann sein,
Bandscheibe vor Fall, Serikal, Bandscheibe vor Fall.
Sehr gut.
Was kann sein?
Ja, Hintumor.
Also irgendwelche cerebralen Prozesse?
Welche? So dort umarsterebildes?
Ich meine allgemein jetzt. Sie haben alles, was Sie aufgezählt haben, sind hier cerebrale Ereignisse.
Meningo, Tumor, was auch immer. Das heißt eigentlich jetzt cerebrale.
Man kann auch so dort umarsterebildes sagen oder nicht?
Sie hat leicht Übelkeit.
Leichte Übelkeit, genau.
Ja.
Und was noch? Was kann ich sagen?
Ja, auch die MR-Ambitgelungverfahren werde ich auch der MRT empfehlen.
Und je nachdem, die körperlichen Untersuchungen, Sehnenreflexe oder Parastese oder Gefühltverlust werde ich auch die detaillierte neurologische Untersuchung.
Sehr gut. Was mir jetzt noch einfällt als die veramserlten Diakonose wäre zum Beispiel eine chronische Sinusitis.
Das kann auch Kopfschmerzen machen, kann Druck auf den Augen machen.
Sie hat gesagt, dass wenn ich den Kopf nach vorne beuge, kriege ich Schmerzen.
Natürlich, wenn man natürlich schon den Kopf nach vorne beugt und Schmerzen hat, muss man auch an eine Meningitis denken.
Wobei sie hatte kein Fieber gehabt.
Oder was machen auch solche Symptome?
Virale Infekte können natürlich auch solche Symptome verursachen.
Kopfschmerzen, Unruhe, Seidung, Duttruckentgleisung.
Sie meinen, dass Encephalitis?
Das sind allgemeine grippale Infekte.
Erkältung, Grippe kann sowas auch machen.
Sollte ich fragen, ob ich etwas höre?
Hätten Sie fragen müssen, ja.
Haben die Kollegen noch Einwände, Fragen, Tütiken, Vorschläge?
Keine Fragen. Alles gut. Hat der Kollege alles richtig gemacht?
Ja, alles gut.
Das heißt, ich fasse nochmal zusammen.
Wir haben hier eine Patientin mit Zephalgin im Rahmen von Blutdruckentgleisung.
Am ehesten bei Hyperthyriose.
Das heißt, sie hat Kopfschmerzen, weil sie hohen Blutdruck hat.
Was ist Ihr Vorschlag? Was machen Sie jetzt mit ihr? Wie therapieren Sie diese Frau?
Nein, was hat sie jetzt voragiert?
Als Therapie?
Stopp, ganz einfach.
Sie haben eine junge Patientin mit einem Blutdruck von 180 zu 100. Was machen Sie jetzt mit ihr? Sie geben doch nicht Schilddrüsen-Tabletten.
Natürlich, die müssen sofort diese Blutdruck reduzieren.
Genau, wir müssen den Blutdruck senken. Mit was senken Sie den Blutdruck?
ACA-Hemas ist schneller.
Was ist hier der bekannteste ACA-Hema in Deutschland?
Nicht Rhamnipril, sondern Rramnipril.
Die Internisten geben Rhamnipril.
Was kann man noch geben, was gibt es noch außer ACA-Hema?
ACA-Hema, Betablocker.
Was fällt Ihnen als Betablocker?
Beloxog.
Welches Inhaltsstoff ist das? Welches Wirkstoff ist das?
Ich erinnere mich nicht ganz sicher, aber das ist Metaprolol.
Was gibt es noch für Blutdruck senkende Medikamente?
Als junge Patienten geben sie Amlodipin.
Welche Gruppe gehört Amlodipin?
Calciumkanal Hema.
Dann gibt es noch die Zartane.
Ja, Kandesartane, ARB Blocker.
Antihypertensiver, die man als erste Wahl geben würde.
Aber was geben Sie, wenn Sie den Blutdruck schnell senken wollen?
Niterosein, Perlinganit.
Schnelles ist Intravenös, Perlinganit.
Perlinganit, was ist das?
Nitroglycerin oder Visagenit.
Nitrospray, es gibt das Nitrospray unter der Zunge.
Es gibt es als Kapseln, die Nitrokapseln.
Das sind die Nitrate.
Das wirkt schnell, aber das hält nicht lange an.
Nach einer halben Stunde steigt wieder der Blutdruck.
Sehr gut.
Sie geben das Spray ja nicht intravenös?
Nein, man gibt gerne das Spray unter der Zunge.
Man sprüht unter die Zunge als Notfallspray.
Das wirkt auch sehr schnell, innerhalb von wenigen Minuten.
Aber das sollte nicht zu viel sein.
Wenn man zu viel sprüht, reicht ein oder maximal zwei Sprühe unter die Zunge.
Ein bisschen im Mund zergehen lassen, dann wird das von den Gefäßen unterhalb der Zunge sehr schnell aufgenommen.
Das wirkt wie intravenös.
Der Blutdruck geht relativ schnell runter.
Aber Sie brauchen eine antihypertensive Therapie, richtig?
Das zweite ist, Sie schauen sich die Schilddrüse nochmal genau an.
Welche Werte kontrollieren Sie noch bei der Schilddrüse, um genau zu wissen, was für eine Hyperturbuse das ist?
T3 und T4.
Richtig, was noch?
Antithyroglobin und Tractyroxin-Receptor antikörperlich.
Genau, die Antikörper wollen Sie bestimmen.
Antithyroglobin, Antithyge und Tract.
Sehr gut, das heißt Sie machen dann noch einen Ultraschall, wollen gucken, ob sie noch Noten hat.
Und dann können Sie, falls nötig, eine Schilddrüsen-Synthographie machen, wenn sie eine Hyperturbuse hat.
In diesem Falle ist es eine Feinnadelbüche, führen Sie Feinnadelbüchen?
Nein, nein, nein. Ganz auf bloß.
Wann macht man die Feinnadelbüchen? Was wollen Sie wissen, wenn Sie eine Feinnadelbüchen machen?
Wenn die Follikülen vergrößert sind.
Wenn Sie wissen wollen, ob das etwas malignes ist.
Ah, malignes.
Dann macht man die Biopsis sonst nicht.
Sonst nicht, ja.
Nicht gleich invasiv. Meistens geht es mit Medikamenten gut.
Okay, gut. Das ist jetzt eine endokrinologische, internistische Aufgabe.
Sie sind Gynäkologe, wir wollen Sie nicht weiter vertiefen. Sehr gut.
Aber das ist eine Notfall. Das ist ja eine Notfall. Das haben Sie jeden Tag in der Gynäkologie.
Genau.
Sehr gut. Wunderbar. Sind noch Fragen von Kollegen oder Kritiken, Vorschläge?
Keine Fragen. Hat der Kollege das alles richtig gemacht?
Also das war gut, Herr Toplak, das war gut. Aber Sie müssen ein bisschen achten, dass Sie die Grammatik richtig anwenden.
Genau.
Sie machen halbe Sätze, Sie machen ein paar Begriffe und dann blubblubblubblub.
Dann gehen Sie weiter.
Da müssen Sie aufpassen. Sie gehen in eine Sprachprüfung.
Wenn jetzt dieser Prüfer ein bisschen blöd kommt und Sie ärgern möchte, dann sagt er, Sie reden nicht gut.
Durchgefahren. Obwohl Sie alles gut können.
Deswegen versuchen Sie einfach volle Sätze, lieber kurze Sätze, Punkt. Dann nochmal neu reden.
Aber versuchen Sie das korrekt aufzusprechen. Sie können das. Sie wissen das, das merke ich.
Das ist auch gut. Sie haben eine Routine. Sie sind in der Hospitation. Reden Sie oft in der Klinik. Okay?
Ja. Mach ich habe.
Machen Sie auch Patientenvorstellungen in der Klinik auch?
Nicht so häufig habe ich.
Machen Sie das. Nehmen Sie Patienten auf, untersuchen Sie, fragen Sie die Patienten.
Und dann machen Sie so wie hier die Vorstellung an den Oberarzt, an den Facharzt, an den Assistentenkollegen.
Sprechen Sie. Und dann sagen Sie auch den Kollegen, die sollen Sie korrigieren, die sollen Sie verbessern.
Okay?
Ich werde so machen.
Genau.
Danke.
Sehr gut. Also das ist gut. Inschallah.
Inschallah.
Okay. Haben Sie die Fragen?
Heute hat niemand etwas gefragt. Die Gruppe ist sehr ruhig. Alles ist okay.
Ich glaube, dass heute niemand etwas fragen will.
Was?
Ich habe es nicht verstanden.
Okay.
Ich habe es nicht verstanden, aber meine Mutter hat es nicht verstanden.
Eine Frage ist gekommen. Mögen Sie das, Ömer?
Ich habe nicht genau verstanden, was Sie mit dem Schwangaschafen betreut haben.
Wenn wir etwas über den Schwangaschafen in der Diagnose von Ferdaq sagen, würden wir es sehr falsch sagen.
Natürlich. Denn der Schwangaschaf ist kein Schwangaschaf.
Nur zwei Jahre lang hat der Patient gesagt, dass ich, als ich im Krankenhaus war,
die gleichen Unverschämtheit wie das hatte.
Dann hatte ich eine hohe Tension.
Der Patient hat mir sogar die Haare gegeben.
Ich möchte Ihnen etwas sagen.
Sie haben etwas über den Schwangaschaf gesagt, aber ich glaube, das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Wir haben nichts über den Schwangaschaf gesagt.
Es gibt keine Probleme mit meinem Kind. Ich bin gut.
Ja, es gibt keine Probleme.
Es ist möglich, dass der Patient im Krankenhaus ist.
Nein. Wir hatten vor zwei Wochen die Regel.
Okay, okay. Danke.
Sie hat gesagt, er ist nicht schwanger, sondern sterilisiert.
Ich habe mir das vorhin nicht gesagt, aber wenn es so etwas gibt,
und ich es nicht verstehe, dann wäre es falsch.
Der Doktor hat gefragt, ob sie Medikamente oder Hormone oder Contra-Ceptiva nimmt.
Der Patient hat geantwortet, nein, sie nimmt keine Hormone, sie nimmt keine Medikamente.
Der Mann ist sterilisiert.
Das heißt, seine Samenleiter sind vom Urodom unterbrochen.
Also sie kann gar nicht schwanger werden.
Ich habe eine Frage.
In der Hyperthansiv-Krisis gibt es auch schwarze Nester, die im Gesicht fliegen.
Wenn ich die Frage habe, ob es Schwerstörungen gibt, dann ist das auch eine Frage.
Ja.
Wenn ich das Thema Schwerstörungen habe, muss ich das genau sagen?
Nein, das ist nicht so.
Schwerstörungen sind einfach zu sagen.
Hm.
Doktor, hat die Antwort genug?
Ja, ich habe schon die Stereo- ...
Ich kann es nicht mehr sagen.
Ich habe mich immer um die Stereo- ...
Okay.
Dann machen wir uns nicht mehr beitragen.
Wir sind dankbar.